okay anytime but thank you cast may I
have your attention please we don't have
a lot of time so let's get on with it
first of all I would like to welcome
Walter back onto the show you may have
done us more of a favor than you ever
imagined
regrettably I also have to inform you
that Hannah has chosen not to renew her
contract I am sure we can all respect
her reasons however on a more optimistic
note I am pleased to announce that
televisions first on-air conception will
still take place yes you witnessed the
initial contact this morning I think you
all know Claudia from her fine work in
the theater Claudia I loved your Ophelia
loved it thank you
Larry please this is a copy of Claudia's
backstory her character's name is Vivian
we intend to entice Truman into the
affair as soon as possible
Claudia will make a pass at the
insurance seminar Truman's attending
details are in your schedules
I hope you're listening to me I don't
have to tell you how critical these next
few weeks will be this takes us into the
next generation when the child is born
the network will be switching over to a
two channel format to chronicle both
lives what happens when trimmin and the
baby are both on camera together there
will simply be duplicate coverage let's
just hope we don't have twins hmm so
when Truman dies we go back to the
single channel format right that will be
all thank you